un procès très médiatisé donc on en
parle avec francine pelletier kranjcar
aux devoirs et bertrand st-arnaud donc
avocat criminaliste
on n'a pas été très surpris de voir ce
verdict aujourd'hui après tout ce qu'on
avait attendre entendu mais n'empêche
que quelque chose qui a peut-être
surpris c'est la dureté du propos du
juge m st-arnaud où il a effectivement
je pense que la plupart des observateurs
n'ont pas été surpris on le sait le juge
devait être convaincu hors de tout doute
raisonnable de la culpabilité de
monsieur ghomeshi donc être certaine de
sa culpabilité pour le trouver coupable
et je pense que la plupart des
observateurs de ce processus attendait
un verdict d'acquittement
mais comme vous venez de mentionner moi
ce qui m'a frappé ce matin c'est le ton
employé par le juge qui par moment est
particulièrement dur vous savez il dit
les plaignantes cacher la vérité entre
ont pu sous serment
ils évoquent même une possible collusion
entre les plaignantes de est trop et les
gens passent là c'est assez dur comme
propos et c'est la princesse qui m'a
surpris le a priori lorsque l'on est
assez surprenant quand même d'assez
surprenant je pars si j'avais pu je
pense qu'il aurait pu rendre le même
verdict
mais peut-être un peu adoucir les termes
utilisés ça aurait été peut-être plus
approprié à mon humble avis est
d'ailleurs pour un juge à cheval sur la
vérité parce qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité c'est ce qui leur reproche il
dit une fausseté lui même il dit que
c'est une femme qui a été agressée
sexuellement ne veux pas retourner vers
son agresseur alors que c'est faux tout
le monde qui connaît un peu cette
situation là c'est vrai dans la violence
conjugale c'est tout c'est vrai dans
l'agression sexuelle surtout dans ce
défi du contexte en fait il ne
comprenait pas le contexte et ses loques
où la question
ne faut-il pas revoir ce type de droit
là comme on l'a déjà fait dans le passé
mais le revoir à la lumière précisément
de ceux de ce jugement là où on voit que
étant donné que l'agression sexuelle
repose uniquement sur une question
crédibilité parce que pas d'autres
preuves parce qu'il n'ya pas d'armes y
auriez de route que la parole de la
plaignante et la parole de l'accusé puis
dans celle ci l'accusé peut toujours se
taire donc ça veut dire que ça serait
toujours le focus là
feux de la rampe sur l'accusé sur la
plaignante et on va essayer de la
détruire ça sort sur sur le banc et si
ce qui est arrivé aujourd'hui elles ont
menacé fans là on fait des graves
erreurs et on pardonne pas ça mais ça
sera toujours ou des avantages des
planètes mais cette année on avait
vraiment parfois l'impression que
c'était le procès des victimes qu'on
faisait et non pas celui de l'accusé
peut-être à tort oui mais en fait
c'était le procès de l'accusé mais
évidemment comme vous pouvez le dire
madame pelletier ça repose est
exclusivement sur le témoignage des
plaignantes
or les dames à leur crédibilité
effectivement sur la crise
est ce que ces personnes là sont dignes
de foi le juif le sait ce qui doit se
demander est ce que ces personnes sont
suffisamment digne de foi pour que je
sois convaincu hors de tout doute
raisonnable que l'accusé coupable
éventuellement que je peux l'envoyer en
prison
alors évidemment le
contre-interrogatoire de l'avocat de la
défense vise essentiellement à poser des
questions qui qui ont effectivement
fortement ébranlé le jeu je vais
assurément parce qu'effectivement on a
pu démontrer lors du temps du contre
interrogatoire que chacune des trois
plaignantes avait n'avait pas donné
l'heure juste à la fois aux policiers à
la poursuite éventuellement en cours
alors c'est très ébranlée comme qui
amène la question qui n'a pas bien fait
son travail parce que comment est ce que
la couronne et la police ont pu laisser
ça passe et non mais moi je pense que
tout le monde a été victime d'un procès
sur médiatisé à partir du moment où
celui-ci
radio-canada a congé en ghomeshi il ya
eu un effet l'on le vieux avait avec les
campagnes dans les médias sociaux
les femmes se sont levés en ciel
exactement comme si on on dénonce et
sert à lui vraiment un mouvement où on
avait l'impression que on en avait
vraiment un ras-le-bol qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose
ces femmes là qui aurait jamais de
porter plainte dans des conditions
différentes sans ce mouvement de
soulèvement là moi j'ai l'impression se
sont senti investi d'une mission sont
consentis qu'il devait aller porter ce
flambeau là elle avait très peur de ne
pas être crues de toute évidence elles
se sont dédiés se sont contredits parce
que elle cherchait la ligne juste là
dedans elle avait la victoire évidemment
mes yeux tout le problème de la couronne
aussi de la police qui est pas que peu
que banques et son enquête sur kiel
une réflexion sur une réflexion à faire
un post mortem à faire tant du côté des
policiers qui avaient mené cette enquête
l'ont-il mené ont-ils retourner toutes
les pierres avant de déposer un dossier
à la couronne et bien sûr la poursuite
ou s'ils devraient faire un post mortem
de comment ça se fait qu'on a pu
échapper ce dossier la couronne qui elle
n'est pas là pour inquiéter elle est là
pour piloter le dossier devant les
tribunaux à partir du dossier dans
lequel je pense qu'il est important
aussi de ne pas généraliser à propos de
ce procès est un procès hors-norme trois
plaignantes qui ne donne pas l'heure
juste à la poursuite à la couronne est
même en cours des plaignantes qui
multiplie probablement de bonne foi des
entrevues dans les médiums et ce à
l'heure on est terriblement pas ce que
ça va donner des munitions à la défense
qui pouvait mettre devant la tribunal
les contradictions entre les entrevues
est ce qu'elle disait en cours des
plaignantes qui deux plaignantes qui
s'envoient cinq mairies courriel vous
savez vous êtes juge l'entendait soit
5000 courriel dont certains disent une
dit à l'autre
je vais tout faire pour que ce ça nous
fait naissent en prison le juge qui
entend surtout faire ici
c'est donc ce pour dire qu'on voit pas
c'est habituellement le seul procès hors
norme et moi même ce que je veux dire ce
soir c'est il faut pas généraliser à
partir de ce procès là moi je pense
qu'on doit avoir confiance dans notre
système de justice est nécessaire d'en
généraliser est ce que quand même ça va
pas avoir un impact sur les autres
femmes qui qui voudraient qu'ils
souhaiteraient dénoncé ans et qui en a
beaucoup qui n'osent pas le faire c'est
sûr
d'ailleurs il semblerait qu'une des
trois plaignantes vient de commencer un
site pour aider les femmes à aller de
l'avant dire tout ce que vous devez
savoir avant d'aller porter plainte dont
il va avoir un mouvement je pense pour
aider les femmes allaient porter plainte
parce que c'est extrêmement important
mais c'est sûr que dans un premier temps
il va voir un refroidissement
moi j'espère que ce refroidissement va
être contré par le mouvement général on
le voit déjà eu des manifestations à
toronto il ya déjà des juristes qui pose
énormément de questions à savoir comment
ça devrait être mené devant les
tribunaux des cas d'agressions sexuelles
est ce qu'il ne faut pas revoir un peu
comment on fait parce que quand je vous
dis ça soit toujours les dés sont
toujours un peu pipés étant donné les
les règles de droit et on est d'accord
avec les règles de droit en faveur de
l'accusé l'a pour l'instant le temps
file m sans ballon et c'est très
difficile
il nous reste quelques parce que c'est
changer les statuts c'est l'émoi le
message que je veux moi je pense qu'il
faut croire notre système de justice à
tous les jours au québec au canada il ya
des plaies des gens qui vont se plaindre
des policiers qui entendent s'est plaint
il ya des ddd témoin qui sont entendus
dans les tribunaux des plaignantes sont
attendus il ya des agresseurs qui sont
condamnés à tous les jours donc c'est un
système qui fonctionne
attention pour ne pas partir d'un cas
hors norme généralisée maintenant est ce
qu'on doit faire une réflexion plus
large en allait commencer d'ailleurs
bien commencé mais c'est beau c'est
lorsque effectivement comment équilibrer
les droits de l'accusé qui sont des
droits constitutionnels avec les droits
des victimes s'est vraiment passé mais
ya du travail à faire parce que quand on
sait que seulement il ya seulement 0.5 %
d'aidés plein qui vont devant les
tribunaux qui ce qu'ils ont qui où
l'accusé condamné
ça veut dire que les femmes sont pas
tellement cru un problème là il ya un
problème à nous avait dit qu'on ne
réglera pas ici ce soir mais je remercie
beaucoup de deux êtres avec d'être venu
en studio merci merci